Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Ask yourself the question,
what is life? If you ask what
the philosopher and a scientist,
they would probably give you
two entirely different answers.
A scientist would be able to go into
detail about the biological intricacies of
life on is talking about cells,
DNA, the taxonomic classifications,
survival, reproduction,
evolution, all that sort of
thing. A philosopher, however,
would focus more on something
like the human experience,
the meaning behind existing.
The questions we ask ourselves about
existence and the guidelines we tend to
employ to live our lives to the fullest
and in fact what a fulfilling life
really is.
Given both of these answers and topics,
which one is more important,
the scientific example or
the philosophical example?
Well, in fact, one could argue that
they are equally as important. However,
this argument is not made
nearly enough as it should be.
Many popular scientists of
the day have to some degree,
agreed upon the profound statement.
Philosophy is dead.
They are good at science has replaced
a function of philosophy that the
scientific method and empirical data
has replaced sitting in a room thinking
about the universe entirely in order
to uncover its aspects and mysteries.
Something like the origin
of the universe for example,
they claim has been taken from philosophy
and is now in the field of science.
In that regard, they are perhaps
somewhat right, you know,
the universe or the physical forces
which shape the universe that we live in
should be taken into science
as much as possible. However,
unfortunately the profound statement that
philosophy is dead is profoundly wrong
and for as respectable and knowledgeable
as these scientists may be making these
kinds of statements only demonstrates
that they aren't as aware of the role of
philosophy in our society and our
individual lives as they should be. Sure.
I mean they are right and
the argument that they make,
it's true that in the past many great
minds just assume they could sort of think
of things and arrive to how
it works and what it is,
which today has been
considerably replaced by science,
but that's a shallow example up the great
breadth of what philosophers did and
still do.
If philosophy is dead,
then it's up to the scientist using only
science to answer some very important
questions. For example, explain
scientifically, objectively,
why is it wrong to kill?
What is theft?
What should I be doing with my life?
Why shouldn't scientists be able to test
medications or even weapons and such
things on humans? Furthermore, science
rest upon results, data the truth,
but what does it mean for
something to be true? You see,
these are questions which are
fundamental to our day to day lives,
but it's not something to which you could
just employ the scientific method to
find out the answer.
So it's simply like you would
something within the field of physics.
It's not that simple.
It's not so simple to try to
employ empiricism to abstractions,
which is what these people who are
claiming philosophy to debt or doing what
kind of government and economic
systems should we have at this?
The scientist may jump to
respond. Oh, that's simple.
We just take it every government
and economic system we have,
try it out in small test groups and
see which one works the best and try to
implement those policies into our modern
society. True to logic and science.
But what do you mean by the best?
While the society,
which is most efficient, but what does
it mean to be an efficient society?
Well, I suppose as a society in
which people are the happiest,
but why is happiness the most important
thing for which we should strive in life?
What is happiness?
What kind of happiness?
The happiness of having a society which
produces free endless candy bars for all
its inhabitants or a deeper happiness of
knowing one has lived a satisfying life.
Who is happiness?
The happiness of the average person.
Does that mean that people above or below
the average who may find happiness and
other things have to suffer?
To what degree do the needs
of the many outweigh the few?
So by this I s I hope you see of course
how making such bland statements leads
to a series of questions,
which I hope reveals to you just how
deeply philosophy takes things. A depth,
which I worry that many people,
especially these people making these
statements that philosophy is dead,
aren't even aware of,
let alone appreciate an offensive
scientists my grow angry at all these
questions and ask,
well,
when's the last time a philosopher ever
got us to the moon or cure a disease?
Good point. I'm not trying to degrade
the role of science here at all.
Those achievements were largely made
directly by scientists, philosophers,
however,
indirectly questions and thoughts and
ideas and morals and ideologies were
floating around. That even led to
things like that happening. We asked,
how can we get to the moon, but we also
asked, why should we go to the moon?
Why do we explore? What does it all mean?
Things that a philosopher would ask,
and it's important to keep in mind here.
That motivation to go to the moon is
as important as technology to get their
face with something like colonizing the
moon and Mars philosopher has to ask the
same questions, which may lead to
scientists to say, just shut up,
dude is freaking cool.
Okay,
that's why we're doing it for the
philosopher has a point look at how we've
destroyed our own planet, for
example, as human society,
a good thing which we should,
which we should spread to other planets
and moons only to pollute and destroy
them too.
And why should we cure diseases?
That's sound like a dumb question to ask,
but it's still one which
has to be answered.
Jonas Salk that didn't
have polio and furthermore,
he didn't even patent his vaccine.
Why did he even bother?
What do we owe the world and why?
These other kinds of questions,
again addressed by philosophy.
Scientists who are critical of philosophy
go at least five times as hard on
religion, and I don't mean to take
a position for or against religion.
That's not the purpose of this channel.
Maybe some channels like to slip
their personal biases into that,
but not this one.
But I will say that many of these big
scientists are factually atheists or
agnostics or some variant of that and
without God or gods or some source for
objective morality, which is, you know,
instructions from a higher
power on how to live.
Basically philosophy
becomes even more important.
As soon as you decide you're an atheist,
an agnostic or something like that,
which is by the way,
a position guided by whether you know,
not whether you know it or not,
philosophy,
you're suddenly hit in the face with
some huge questions about what it is to
well, to even exist. Really an atheist
is all of a sudden faced with nihilism,
faced with the belief that nothing
matters. What does that mean?
Does that mean it's okay to do anything,
shoot people steal, burn down a house,
et Cetera? Most atheists would
say, no, that's still wrong,
but we're a Christian or Muslim or Hindu
or something like that would justify it
being wrong based off their belief
that their dad say it is wrong.
The atheist has to go deeper and that
is done through it philosophy. So again,
when a scientist is analyzing bacteria
and the lab doing something which he or
she may claim is purely biological,
purely scientific,
they may feel comfortable saying
something like philosophy is dead,
but there isn't much time to
study bacteria in a society
which is convinced that
we should live in a dictatorship in which
we worship ants and slave people with
green eyes and avoid technology because
of the harm it brings because we have
abandoned philosophy. That is another
very important argument to consider.
By the way,
what if science and technology leads to
what's being unhappy should be continued
to pursue it in this society?
You'd probably be pretty unhappy.
Your lab was destroyed by soldiers. Your
job as a microbiologist is now illegal.
You live under a dictator now and if
you have green eyes, you're a slave.
You might protest. This is against their
rights, but the dictator would laugh.
What rights? The right to free
speech, the right to live freely,
essentially human rights.
He makes you a deal.
If you can prove that these
rights exist unless you go,
unfortunately for you,
you may be spending some time in slavery,
used to be value our rights and
exercise them on a daily basis.
Even if we don't think about them.
For many of us,
they are intrinsic to who we are,
but they can't scientifically be proven
to exist and therefore they can be
easily stripped from you.
Rights exists because a handful
of intelligent people I eat,
philosophers decided that they should,
and the common person then agreed to
mutually respect and uphold them beyond
that.
Places for people who abuse these rights
called prisons were created in order to
uphold them. So again, we come
to these big important questions.
What is life all about? How should I
live mine? How should we build society?
What role do I have insights society
and why, et Cetera, et cetera.
Philosophers give a wide range of answers,
some argue that we should
dedicate ourselves to
upholding the greatest society
at all costs. Sort of that the whole
is more than the sum of its parts.
Some are less collectivist, but still
argue that by being born into society,
be signed. His social contract in which
we agreed to follow laws and participate
respectfully,
that we have a duty to society.
Some say that's nonsense and the rules
of society change with who is in it and
that we shouldn't force people to
participate in it in voluntarily.
Some say we should vote on decisions.
Other people say the average
person is too dumb to vote.
We need strong authority figures
and make decisions for us.
Some say taxes are justified in that day
can be utilized to improve our society.
Others say Tech Station has stepped.
Some say owning something like land
but they don't use is justifiable.
Others say the property's theft.
Some say we should focus on maximizing
our own existence over coming barriers to
live the best life we possibly can.
Some would say that society comes second
to the individual and that we should
delve as society as a union
of self interested people
who aren't subservience to
ideologies or abstractions.
Some say happiness is the ultimate golf
for which people should strive to get of
life and of these there are thousand
interpretations of what happiness is and
how we should go about
achieving it. Some, however,
would argue against
something like hedonism.
You could go on for days
exploring these questions.
Well actually humans have gone on for
thousands of years asking these questions
and we still don't have definite answers
that everybody seems to agree on.
Some I concluding point here to anyone
who has followed what's called scientism.
The belief that philosophy is dead and
the science can take over and answer all
questions is that the very existence of
science rest upon foundations made by
philosophy. Empiricism rests
on philosophical argumentation
for us effectiveness.
The argument that we should employ
science to improve our lives is a
philosophical debate.
The very societies that we have created,
which allows science to even exist in
all its modern glory are dependent upon
philosophical arguments for
the existence of such things.
So no philosophy is not dead.
It's alive and arguably better than ever.
Science is not a separate
process from philosophy.
They are very closely intertwined.
To the point where I would say that
anyone who calls himself a scientist,
anyone who claims to wake up in the
morning with a desire to understand the
world, needs to give some
consideration to philosophy.
Even if you're not a scientist,
anyone who seeks to live a fulfilling
life should give some time and thought to
philosophy because as Socrates tells us,
the unexamined life is not worth living.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked off
fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.